one of the things that we know today
is that
the viruses
bacteria
parasites and other pathogens
surround us and coexist with
hosts
like humans and one of the things that
we would like to understand is what
differentiates specific pathogenic
microorganisms from non-pathogenic
microorganisms
so this leads us to this concept of a
viral home
viruses are obviously some of the most
clearly understood pathogens
they actually are not characterized as
living microorganisms but they only live
in a host they can only replicate within
a host
and when we think about viruses we can
think about the virum or the collection
of all the viruses that are present in a
specific environmental sample
environment here can be the human gut
the human lungs it could be the water
that we drink
or it could be anything around us and so
viron
or micro
biome are these
collections of microorganisms that we
can sample and clearly identify
now within the biorum or the microbiome
we can start characterizing the specific
individual
microorganisms
and one of the important things is that
because of the next generation
sequencing technology we now have a
variety of viruses
bacteria parasites that are
characterized at the genomic level
now the genomic revolution that
originally started because we wanted to
understand the human genome has in
parallel led to an explosion of the
number of viral bacterial and
other types of microorganism genomes
being sequenced and studied
and here you can see just a glimpse of
how much information is available and
you can see here that the most studied
viruses for example are the viruses that
are commonly found to be pathogenic to
humans
now obviously we can kind of understand
the logic behind this for example just
if we look
at the scale at which covid19 is being
sequenced we can see that the major
outbreaks of
infectious diseases like stars one ebola
zika mers and now covet 19 have been the
spikes in sequencing why do we want to
sequence these genomes and why
particularly do we want to sequence
pathogenic genomes
well one of the things that we want to
try to understand when we're sequencing
these pathogens is the specific recipe
that these pathogens employ
to be effective at what they do which is
to replicate evade our immune response
and ultimately adapt to the different
types of responses that typically work
but in their cases they're not working
to overcome and continue and spread
within the population
so these pathogens
that we are going to study in this
program are going to be studied using
next generation sequencing to understand
their genome and then we're going to
apply the same technology to understand
the response how does the human
immune system respond to these different
pathogens how does it vary across
different types of disease
manifestations and how can we
characterize those interventions that we
can design based on this interaction
that we understand because of next
generation sequencing data so really the
critical thing here is to understand
this technology
how exactly does it work but also how
can we analyze such data and how can we
translate the analysis to biological
insights that are actionable that are
informative and actionable
so what is
next generation sequencing and now we're
going to start with thinking about next
generation sequencing in the context of
pathogens how can we use next generation
sequencing to understand the genomic
structure of viruses and bacteria and
how can we learn to identify important
variation
that we think leads to
their
their manifestation of disease how do
they cause disease
metagenomic and viral sequencing can be
of several different types
specifically we can look at targeted
regions that we already know for example
ribosomal rna
is one way to look at only bacteria
because bacteria have ribosomal rna that
is different in structure from uh for
example human ribosomal rna and so
that's how we can amplify a particular
type of a sequence to identify only
bacterial dna or rna
another example for targeted sequencing
is what we hear for star scope 2 when we
only want to look at
for example variants of concern that
affect the
spike protein and so then we know how to
amplify only the region that contains
the sequence for the spike protein so we
can sequence particular regions by
amplifying them and that's called
targeted sequencing
another type of sequencing is total dna
or rna when we're not looking for any
particular region but we're saying let
us just extract all of the genomic
material from a particular sample and
sequence everything
and then finally you can see here
amplicon environmental in the same
example when we have a particular type
so one type targeted would be let's
target the spike gene another one let's
do a type of a sequence and we'll
understand the composition of a
particular sample
now these are very different approaches
but they rely on the same technology so
to help you learn in detail we recommend
these three particular uh um
articles that you can read through on
your own and we'll share at the end of
today's session the links to these
articles that will help you understand
how these types of sequencing approaches
are helping us understand uh the
presence and and characteristics of
different pathogens
now let's talk about sequencing
specifically in the context of
viral
communities
in bacterial communities right so
microorganisms again pathogens so a lot
of times one of the challenges with
metagenomics when we have an
environmental sample that contains a lot
of different present organisms
we would like to understand how all of
these different organisms are
characterizing the environmental sample
now
in bacterial examples there's always a
challenge because with bacteria we don't
we're not able to
isolate and grow individual bacteria
only one percent of bacterial
isolates could be grown in the lab so
one of the questions would be well how
do these bacterial
communities exist in real life in in the
real world and to do that we have the
approach of metagenomics with viruses
it's the same thing
not only do we have viruses interacting
with other viruses these viruses also
interact with other bacteria in fact the
majority of viruses are
bacterial
viruses viruses that only infect
bacterial cells
so when we think of a particular virus
that is causing a disease we would like
to understand the community or the
environment where that virus came from
and in many cases we would like to
characterize that particular one
pathogen
how that pathogen is different from the
others that it lives together with or
that interacts with others uh like them
and then understand how the sequence of
that particular virus can be in a piece
of information that we can use how can
we use that piece of information
in viral outbreaks we would like to take
a clinical specimen for example a human
blood sample
and we would like to find
all of the viruses that are present in
that clinical sample
for example if we have a
temperature if we have
vomiting if we have cough right we want
to understand what is the particular
pathogen causing the manifestation of
that disease and to do that what we can
do is we can sequence everything that is
in that sample that includes the host
genome and maybe genomic material
as well as anything else that is present
there
sometimes we already know
so if we have a particular
virus that we think is causing the
infection right we can design a primer
specifically amplify those regions that
we know should be present based on the
virus strain that we think is present in
this particular patient and then try to
understand is that the same strain that
we expect it to be or is it somehow
different from the reference that we
have
now in many cases we also have multiple
causes of a condition right and so
what's important at the first stage is
to try to understand what all is present
in a particular sample and we can do
that because
we have different types of data where we
can store the resources about potential
organisms that we can find for example
we have a database of microorganisms or
a database of viral genomes and we can
now compare and contrast what we find in
a sample with what we will find in a
particular sample that we have
or or what is known to be in a database
now to understand how these different
techniques are going to be useful in the
context of next generation sequencing we
have to understand the types of files